morning all uh we are hoping to be on
the polish border with ukraine shortly
where there remains a constant flow of
people arriving from ukraine we are of
course now eight days into the russian
invasion and the u.n refugee agency says
a million people have so far fled
ukraine more than half of them heading
to poland well overnight russia has
seized control of its first ukrainian
city though ukraine's president has
disputed this uh well these are the main
developments this morning russian
officials say the black sea port of
carson is now under their complete
control
ukraine's government says they are still
defending the city but carson's mayor
confirms there are no longer any
ukrainian forces there the u.n refugee
agency says that one million people have
fled ukraine since the start of the
invasion
ukraine says that more than 2 000
civilians have been killed as the
international criminal court opens its
investigation
into possible war crimes
u.s intelligence suggests that the
russian military convoy approaching kiev
is now 16 miles away from the city
center that is two miles closer than
yesterday but their progress is said to
have stalled our international affairs
editor dominic whitehorn reports
the rumble of russian heavy armor
rolling through residential streets in
first light a ukrainian films the
russian army parked up outside
armed black figures fan out through its
streets the mayor of the strategic black
sea port says they forced their way into
the council building as he begged them
not to shoot people
a resident told sky news he believes
kirsten is now fully under russian
control
since i saw the tanks outside this
morning the russian military forces i
haven't seen anything from the ukrainian
organizations after that i mean no
police there is no ukrainian military
here so i believe that the city is in
100
in
[Music]
ukrainian russian control actually
russia says it's only striking military
targets
not here in urban on the outskirts of
the ukrainian capital
nearby people resort to flee on foot
carrying what they can through an
apocalyptic landscape
just a week in the devastation is
already staggering in the decimated
village of garenka olga somehow managed
to survive an airstrike
overnight ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski again vowed the resistance
against russia's aggression would go on
wherever they go
they will be destroyed
they will not have come here they will
not have food they will not have one
quiet moment
the occupiers will receive only one
thing from ukrainians
ukraine's second largest city kharkiv
long queues for food and aid
the city's railway station desperate
scenes as people try to leave
in berlin ukrainians are reunited the
unhcr says a million people have fled
ukraine already in just a week
here in russia fury is growing hundreds
again held in protest in saint
petersburg
doing this takes courage and risks
arrest and a beating
many are trying to leave as russia's
economy begins to buckle under western
sanctions
and the country's isolation grows
dominick waghorn sky news moscow
well meanwhile police in moscow have
reportedly detained two women and
five children who wanted to lay flowers
at the ukrainian embassy
photos uploaded to social media saw the
youngsters sitting in a detention cell
as you can see they are holding signs
they say
no to war
which they intended to leave outside the
embassy
uh while there have been plenty of
people fleeing from ukraine and in the
process leaving behind most of what they
own their homes their possessions and
for many their pets families have been
torn apart well let's just get an update
on the numbers that have so far been
forced to flee
over a million people according to the
unhcr
have now fled ukraine in the last seven
days the u.n refugee agency says that's
the quickest exodus of refugees this
century
now that means well two percent of
ukraine's population of 44 million have
left in just a week
for its part poland has taken more than
half of all refugees
we've also had a country by country
breakdown of refugee numbers in the last
hour at hungary well it has seen over
139 000 arrivals tens of thousands for
moldova slovakia and romania as well
over 47 000 people have in fact gone to
russia
with 357 people moving to belarus the
rest of europe while taken together
they've seen nearly 90 000
refugees
uh well as we were saying the un uh puts
a figure of a million uh fleeing ukraine
since the invasion began but more are
currently on the move they're trying
desperately to get away from the
fighting people are leaving dinipro a
strategically important city bridging
east and west ukraine there has been no
shelling as yet but russian jets are
flying closer triggering alarms on a
daily basis
they are then traveling
943 kilometers almost 600 miles in old
money across ukraine to live on packed
trains full of people trying to get away
from the russians
our correspondent john sparks
made the journey with some of them
no one knows if or when the train will
come
but in the city of dunipro there are
thousands of people keeping watch
their past and their present has been
packed into bags
while their future lies on platform one
the trains head west to the city of la
vie which stands as some sort of beacon
but nobody wants to leave their home
how do you feel very bad very very bad
i i am very angry why
because putin
weighty decisions are made in a moment
by those who have no time to think how
do you feel in your heart not so
that's beginning to slow down now and
there is going to be one almighty
crush
as people try to get on
this map's not in a good way
but they're going to get him on
propelled by fear they battle to board
as the train attendants beg them to step
back
bags are hoisted from passenger to
passenger and within a few minutes the
train is full
careful don't fall don't come in he begs
the majority on this train are women and
children
men between 18 and 60 are expected to
stay and fight
so those on board made their solitary
farewells natalia nakrassa is taking her
son to safety her husband will stay
behind
some feel shame for leaving their loved
ones
others struggle to make sense of it as
the train speeds them away from the
front lines
oleg is from the city of vallnavaca
and his daughter sonia is terribly
confused
[Music]
the train stops in towns and villages as
we travel through the night and on every
platform there are people trying to get
in
what are they doing they can't get on
says one the conductor refuses to open
the doors
irina and her son have been traveling
for days after her hometown was attacked
by the russians
she says she'll never be the same
[Music]
they arrived
to the sound of air raid sirens a
reminder of everything they left behind
so the majority will continue this
journey moving west into the arms of the
european union
a great exodus of reluctant travelers
wondering if they'll ever make it home
john sparks sky news in western ukraine
[Music]
uh well you will have noticed this week
and indeed last week uh the minister of
defense popping up their intelligence
update every morning here is the very
latest just dropping in the last few
minutes a couple of points to make about
this the first point that they make that
huge column
of material and uh
and boots on the ground advancing on key
level according to the ministry of
defence that remains some 30 kilometers
60 miles from the center of the city
they say it's been delayed by a
combination of factors ukrainian
resistance of course mechanical
breakdown also congestion but well
certainly if you've been watching the
channel over the past few days you will
have noticed at little progress over the
past few days
uh as for the cities that have currently
been encircled uh kharkiv cherny and
maria paul
well according to the ministry of
defense intelligence those do remain in
russian hands
however that situation in and around
carson the russians claiming to have
taken it the mayor of carson suggesting
that there were no ukrainians still
defending the situation from the
ministry of defense's perspective the
military situation quotes remains
unclear
at that final point there the russian
defense ministry forced to admit that
almost 500 soldiers have been killed as
the ministry of defence
points out
the number of those killed and wounded
will almost certainly be considerably
higher
let's head now to the west of ukraine
where we will find skies adam parsons
adam
uh yeah good morning from lev which is
right on the west of ukraine quite a
long way from from any of the fighting
in in kharkiv or kiev or kirsan where of
course
we now await news of whether that city
is under russian control but but this
place far from the fighting nowadays is
affected not so much by bombs or attacks
but by the ripples by the after effects
and those are manifested by all these
people that you can see around me this
has become ukraine's city of of refugees
uh and of flight because
this is the place where so many
ukrainians so many i'd say people from
from all over the world are coming to in
order to plan their escape
from uh from the fighting
uh not just by the way fleeing ukraine
although clearly a lot of them do
this is about displacement it's about
people coming here because they've got
nowhere else to go and they feel that
this is a place a city of sanctuary if
you look around here we've just seen
dozens of people walking past us
a train maybe off a bus
and you can see a lot of red cross
volunteers uh here to uh to support them
it is it's cold here uh it's been
snowing overnight uh and there are
plenty of people who need who need food
they need soup
they need some kind of accommodation
they come through this building here
this big white building uh that is uh
levi's main railway station and from
there you can get a train uh directly
out to the polish border and through the
polish border it's uh it's how we came
into levith
in the first place and today
is a milestone because the un says that
today the number of people who have left
ukraine has breached a million they say
it's about a million and five thousand i
think those figures of course will be
going up all the time
just over half of those people have gone
to poland just over five hundred
thousand have now gone supposedly
rest of them going to hungary and
slovakia moldova romania
uh some by 48 000 have at some point
fled to
russia
a tiny number have gone to belarus and
then about i think about 70 000 have
gone to other eu nations
uh so this place itself is has the sense
i have to say of a refugee camp
as that combination of people who are
relieved to be here
but also they didn't want to come they
are
anxious to move to move on
but like much of ukraine
wherever you go you can't escape that
sense two things i would say a anxiety
and fear and anger about this invasion
but second everywhere you go that sense
of resilience
and pride in the nation you see the
flags uh ukrainian flags flying all over
this city all over uh the country
that is the position here in ukraine a
lot of these people are leaving here and
trying to find a safe place by going
across the polish border and that
jane sucker is uh is where you are good
morning to you
where adam is the liv of travelling too
in the last few minutes of training
people on it from lev have come from all
over
the country in ukraine
with me is a lady called anna who has
traveled from kiev um anna just tell me
a little bit about your journey
it's like it's crazy where
when you
like stay in a
huge bunch of people
where you understand like all
[Music]
senses
of each people is uplifted
and you can understand
like that people became like animals
like it's it's exhausting and
it's really crazy but
but
sometimes you should
take
control in your
hand
and
like protect all the people and
for example i had situation
yesterday in lev
train station it was huge a bunch of
people
and all volunteers they cannot uh
they worked so hard and they cannot
take
this
huge energy from people because they
should protect them
and sometimes people
don't understand it they under control
so sometimes we need to take
and say
people are just exhausted aren't they
people are so so tired what
how long did it take you to get from
kiev
two days and to be honest we're very
lucky i heard some stories like people
stay on a borderline for
nine days on the street of course
there are some shelters for them but
it's very cold and it's
exhausted and
to wait some train they can stay in
[Music]
underground uh for uh step four station
like
uh three days
just three days
old ladies with all like sickness of
course they
they are not young anymore so they have
a lot of problems with issues with heart
with
psychology problems a lot of people have
had the
shark attack
so it's
[Music]
thank you so much for talking to us
today i know you just arrived thank you
for support thank you guys thank you
it's been a really hard journey for so
many people and this isn't the end of it
of course she's come to poland she's met
some friends and and family but what is
her life going to be now you know she's
left her whole life behind um
let's move from here in poland back to
westminster and talk to the minister of
state for security and borders damien
hines and and damian you know talking to
anna there and she's had a dreadful
experience she's she's been traveling
for two days uh why is it when she gets
to a country like here like poland she's
been waved through without any
really significant visa checks but
wishing to come to the uk it wouldn't be
the same case
well look first of all all of our hearts
go out to
these families mothers children who have
had these extraordinary difficult
journeys in the most horrible
circumstances and
look our country is absolutely stepping
up to the plate as other friends and
neighbors across europe are doing to
make sure that in this time of their
greatest need we are there for the for
the ukrainian people and we've as as you
know jim we've we're creating two big
new routes
uh to to enable um uh people fleeing
from the from the conflict in in ukraine
to be to be welcomed in our country and
supported and that is absolutely the
right thing to do
but they still have to go through the
visa processing don't they and there are
you know countries like france i'm just
wondering
what concerns we have that countries
like ireland and france don't have
so well we're putting in place uh an
absolutely expedited process to do that
we've got um application centers um
being set up i mean close to where
close to where people are rather than
having to to go necessarily um elsewhere
we're staffing up our applications that
is right across europe because of course
once people
people from ukraine
have uh schengen rights to move into a
country like poland or the other
or some of the other nearby countries
then they can also move um through the
schengen area just a matter of course
that's not to do with the current
conflict but just anyway so so they may
come to application centers elsewhere we
want to make sure
that we have the warmest most supportive
welcome possible and so things like this
the extended family program which we
have
which um
for which hundreds of thousands of
people a couple hundred thousand uh is
the estimate uh it may be eligible for
but also there's community sponsorship
routes
where um local groups organizations
churches local authorities individuals
can can support an
an individual a family coming from
ukraine it could be somebody they know
but it may be that they don't of course
know anybody
uh in the country and then we can match
them up um this will be up and running
in in a few weeks time can match them up
uh to somebody who needs that support to
make sure we're absolutely maximizing
what we're able to do
why is it taking a few weeks
so it's not just to be clear it's not
so the the the existing family
that's that's one particular there's one
particular aspect
i think family system is is up and
running now the extended family system
is going to be is tomorrow
and then yeah if you could to create a
system to match up
people from in from in country with uh
with families and local community
organizations here that will take a bit
longer for that matching system but we
do already have of course
a resettlement community and support
program that's operated for example to
welcome people from from the syrian
conflict in the past so we'll be able to
do that we'll be able to do that quickly
there is absolutely no uh pension of any
kind of delay here people need help now
um we're conscious there are very large
numbers of people
in poland and romania and elsewhere we
also are giving support to to the region
that's very important as well to our
friends for example in poland to make
sure there is humanitarian assistance
but we do recognize of course
that people need that and they need to
be able to to get away poland and others
can't deal with it all on their own
absolutely not we are there and the
other countries in europe are there to
make sure the support is in place uh for
those for those families who've been to
this most appalling time
so do you know how many visa
applications have been submitted and
been processed since last wednesday
so um so far a
relatively small number i can't even i
can't give an exact number a relatively
smaller but we expect that to grow
rapidly so we are we're stepping up the
the capacity
thousands or tens
the capacity we're putting in place now
we're very soon up to
capacity for six thousand a week but
we'll keep it under review and if it
needs to increase it will increase that
sorry that's just in the immediate
region there's also course application
centers
across europe and as i say because of
in the schengen area because people will
be able to move and some will we also
expect there to be applications made in
some of those other centers as well so
we will absolutely make sure but you
must know roughly how many
ukrainian people have granted visas in
the last week i mean i know you can't
give me an exact figure but but are we
talking a handful or are we talking a
few hundred
look it's happening it's happening all
the time and changing all the time we'll
be growing all the time but what i'm
telling you is what i can tell you is
like the number of appointments that
are available in a normal normal
circumstance 890 appointments are
available in a week in that region we
are growing that
uh already it's been to three thousand
it's gonna assume it's six thousand so
that gives you an order of magnitude
kind of week by week but that's just in
the immediate region there can be
applications further afield as well and
most importantly don't if i may
we will keep reviewing that so we make
sure that the capacity is there so we're
not keeping people waiting unnecessarily
we can progress with this quickly and
help people to to
to to get on in their lives bearing in
mind that it's still going to be
hugely difficult circumstances of course
when they do arrive in our country and
that's why things like the family
support links and these
community sponsoring programs are are
really really valuable because they help
people to
um you know to make sure that children
can you know are well settled
in education to to to be looking for
for work or to navigate the benefit
system all of these things
are an important part of the overall
world
they are but but it does seem to me that
that you know we're talking now about
the biggest movement of people this
century across europe and there are
hundreds of thousands pouring into all
of these countries and it from what
you're saying
the uk haven't yet processed more than a
few hundred
it's it's as complex for poland and
romania and all of these other countries
isn't it as it is for the uk
yeah so
so these two new programs are just
starting as i say the
extended family uh programs will start
from from tomorrow
and the community resettlement um
sponsorship program that that that will
take a a wee while longer for good
reason because you've got to set these
things up in place
correctly and make sure the safeguarding
is there and and so on to make sure it
works for what works for everybody and
but my commitment is absolutely that we
will make sure we can
uh we we can work through the people who
want to fight this country and this is
it is a it is a big offer i mean you
talk about hundreds of thousands there
are hundreds of thousands of people will
be eligible for these um for just you
know for this extended family program
and the new community sponsorship
program it is a big it is a big volume
off and rightly so in these
circumstances when all of us
all of us around
the world have to and and are pulling
together to make sure we are there to
stand with ukraine in this
hardest possible set of circumstances
that people find themselves in these
terrible
traumas that you know children are going
through
separated from separated from a parent
and so on to make sure that we can make
that process as at least as smooth as as
it can be in these circumstances
uh we've just had a bit of breaking news
some reports that there's been a big
u-turn at the international paralympic
committee uh saying yesterday that the
russian and belarusian athletes could
compete but not under the national flag
now saying
that they aren't going to
compete haven't been able to confirm
that as yet but what would your reaction
be if that was the case
well as you say that clearly is breaking
news because you've just broken it to me
i didn't know that if that is true
i i would welcome that i've made the
decision that the that the committee
made
i know these are difficult circumstances
but i think it is incredibly important
the strongest possible message the
committee thought for having set put in
place the strongest possible measures i
don't think that was the strongest
possible set of measures what you've
just described is the strongest possible
set of measures and so if that is true
i welcome that
let's just briefly before we leave you i
come back to the situation on the ground
in ukraine um when you look at what we
we think has happened in kirsan um and
and what is happening in places like
mario paul and russia seems to have this
policy now of trying to cut off
towns and villagers and almost starve
the people out do you think
that this is what russia is trying to do
and if so how concerned are you about
this tactic
look at how concerned i'm at we're all
desperately concerned i mean this is a
ruthless
invading force um i mean when it comes
to
tactics and military strategy
i'm i'm not going to
second guess what vladimir putin what he
might be thinking what might be in his
head but we do know that this is a this
is a ruthless a ruthless force um and
extremely i mean obviously imminently
right now for ukraine but actually
dangerous for the wider region for
europe and the world
and that's why it's so important and i
mean the bravery the tenacity that we've
seen from
from the people of ukraine my god we
have all been we have all been taken
aback and it is so important that we do
everything we can
to to support them in in what they're
doing and to make sure and this is where
all the sanctions and and you know we've
got the economic crime bill transparency
and enforcement come coming through on
monday in parliament why all these
things are so important to make sure
that we absolutely make
make the regime hurt
okay damian hines thank you very much
and thank you very much for joining us
this morning on sky news
well you're watching sky news breakfast
we are live in shemesh on the polish
border with ukraine where there remains
a constant flow of people arriving from
ukraine the united nations refugee
agency says the number of refugees
leaving ukraine in the last week has now
officially passed the one million mark
which more than half of them have come
here to poland and the humanitarian
situation is growing by the day well
christine
pirro lackis is from the un refugee
agency and and she joins me now really
good to talk to you thank you so much
for joining us today and what is the
latest you're able to tell us about the
figures as you know them of the numbers
of people who are moving at the moment
so as you just said there's one million
people that have now fled ukraine that
have sought safety and protection in
neighboring countries
um again as you mentioned poland has
received more than half
three quarters of of the number are
women and children
it's women children and elderly that
have been escaping and seeking
protection with literally only small
pieces of luggage
and the clothes on their backs um
a lot of the people um
the situation is also dire within
ukraine there's one million people that
have been internally displaced
and there's heavy fighting and there's a
lot of casualties people remain trapped
um and for us um you know we have
pre-positioned supplies within ukraine
but it's been really really difficult to
get those emergency supplies to people
in need
how does it how does it change things
when
the bulk of the people traveling are
women and children because when we look
at a lot of the migrant crises and the
refugee crisis that we've seen over the
last few years it has been a real
mixture and it has been uh predominantly
a lot of young men um
what are the different priorities and
what are the different steps you have to
take
so right now um you know unhcr has been
noticing like you said there's a lot of
women and children
as i mentioned three quarters have been
fleeing to the neighboring countries
it's proving to be a challenge um
we're offering psychological support to
the women and children as they cross the
borders because they've been traumatized
by what's been happening
there have also been instances where
women have left
their children at the border and to go
and return to ukraine to continue
fighting with their husbands in those
instances um we've uh
are working with the national
authorities to identify
um children that have been unaccompanied
and were um identifying them ensuring
them that they're in the um the nation's
um you know child protection services
that they're being protected and that
they're being looked after the next step
will of course try to be family reunion
in these circumstances so the situation
is changing all the time but we it's
it's especially hard for the women and
children that have been playing because
there's so many of them
how many children are are in that
situation how many women are leaving
their children at the border and going
back to fight do you think
we don't know but what unhcr is at the
border and it's looking after all of
unaccompanied children that are crossing
and is ensuring that they're being
protected that you know the national
authorities are looking to put them in
protection services and that they're
being um cared for
so that's the situation
with the women and children
the national authorities as i am sure
you're aware in poland
they're doing an excellent job to you
know provide
safety and shelter
and
in temporary you know accommodation
so we're acting as backup for the polish
authorities to all the national
authorities
you know we're not there to
to take over but we're there to help and
that's what we're doing we're assisting
all the national authorities by bringing
in you know we're ramping up our
resources in the area we're bringing in
emergency supplies
we're going to be distributing already
in moldova
yesterday we shipped you know thousands
of thermal blankets more are on their
way
and the same is in romania where we're
acting with the united we're working
with the government
on the task force to provide emergency
supplies when needed
i mean are you talking about you know
one or two children this is happening to
i know you can't give us
absolute numbers or is it actually a a
really significant issue
we don't know but we are there because
this is something we've been noticing
and of course unhcr that is our job is
to make sure that all unaccompanied
minors are being looked after
what do you make of reports that we've
been carrying on sky news and people
we've spoken to
who say that that people who are black
south asian mediterranean are being
separated from people who are white on
the ukrainian side of the border
so what we're doing is we're advocating
to all the national governments the high
commissioner has spoken to top level
officials
and so to ensure that all the borders
remain open that everyone regardless of
nationality and race is allowed in two
countries to seek safety and protection
everyone has the right to seek asylum
and we're being assured by all the
national governments we're advocating on
this the high commissioner is
and
all the national governments have
assured unhcr that the borders will
remain open to everyone
christine christine pirro blackous
senior external relations officer at
unhcr uh really good to talk to you a
reminder of our breaking news this hour
and the international paralympics
committee has decided to ban russian and
belarusian athletes from the paralympic
games about to start in beijing it
follows a specially convened meeting
this morning let's give you uh what the
ipc has had to say in the last few
minutes
the athlete entries from rpc
and npc belarus
to the athletes from the impacted
countries we are very sorry that you are
affected by the decisions or yoga that
your government took last week in
breaching the olympic truths
you are victims of your government's
actions
after welfare is and always will be a
key concern for us
as a result of today's decision 83 para
athletes are directly impacted by this
decision
however if rpc and npc belarus remain
here in beijing
the nations will likely withdraw we will
likely not have viable games if this
were to happen the impact will be far
wider reaching
i hope and pray that we can get back to
a situation when the talk and focus is
fully on the power of sport to transform
the life of persons with disabilities
and the best of humanity
thank you
welcome back to poland we're in chamesh
which is on the border or close to the
border
with ukraine and this is the place where
a lot of people who've been traveling on
trains from viv uh are coming into the
trains are coming in here they're coming
in in uh small
time gaps and then people who are coming
off those trains are being met by uh
some people that they know and also some
people who've been organized to help
take them on to other countries while
the united nations has overwhelmingly
backed a motion censuring the russian
invasion ukraine's president has pleaded
for more international assistance and
the united states has warned that russia
faces massive unprecedented consequences
here's our u.s correspondent mark zone
america's top diplomat was at church
this ash wednesday a ukrainian church in
washington dc a guest of ukraine's
ambassador to the u.s oksana makarova
you're our star
inside anthony blinken's demeanor was
that of a man who wishes he could do
more if only the risks of escalation
with russia were not so grave it's in
the most difficult moments that
our faith is tested
this is a difficult moment but i know
that
we will
you will the ukrainian people are
showing
that they are rising to uh to the test
all along pennsylvania avenue the
ukrainian flag is flying but across town
at the state department the message was
for the russian people we know
many of you want no part of this war
you
like ukrainians like americans like
people everywhere want the same basic
things
good jobs clean air and water
the chance to raise your kids in safe
neighborhoods
in new york at the united nations an
historic vote to condemn russia to call
for it to pull out of ukraine not
binding of course but the message was
overwhelming
in red with russia north korea eritrea
syria and belarus are putin's only true
friends
among the 34 abstentions perhaps avenues
for diplomacy to end all this
china has said it's engaged with both
sides india too and the ukrainians say
it could not be more urgent
as the president of ukraine asked
what was the point of repeating the
slogan never again in 80 years
it's already clear that the goal of
russia is not
an occupation only
it is genocide
the president has now ordered sanctions
on russia's defense industry and on
belarus too it's intentionally targeting
civilian areas there are over 2 000
civilians there they are
the effort to find an end to all this
will continue
mark stone sky news in washington
well one week on from the start of the
invasion from and moscow has claimed
that it seized the ukrainian port city
of marriott no sorry of curson
what does this mean for the people
who've lived there most of their life in
a free and democratic country well let's
talk to svetlana zarina she is in curson
for us this morning and svetlana
both russian and ukrainian officials
claim that they are in control of the
city what is the situation as far as you
understand it what can you see
uh hi uh this situation here now
is very tensed we're sitting at our
homes
some people sitting are in the basements
a lot of houses are burned uh they are
occupied the city russian soldiers are
all over the city
and we are afraid to leave our houses
only volunteers or
uh men uh trying to leave the house buy
food for some who need it
and for somebody who need it for
children for
women for
hospitals but it's
like very scary because we hear a lot of
explosions uh especially at night and
early in the morning
and we're trying not to leave because
i'm here with my grandmother now and um
we have enough food for couple weeks so
we try not to leave because it's very
dangerous right now and our government
asked us to sit at home and this is the
way how we can help our army and to take
care of ourselves
so as far as you are aware it is russian
soldiers who are on the streets not
ukrainian ones
no no uh we don't have professional
ukrainian army in our city right now
and they are afraid they can't now to
kick russian soldiers out of the city
because
russian soldiers are in all the living
districts of our town so it's dangerous
to
fight with them and
they ask us to wait until they can do
that
so we trust our guys
we hope it
sorry
sorry to turn to represent
officials are saying that not a single
residential area in kursan was bombed um
what do you know about that is that true
uh it's not true uh the area of your son
was bombed just apartment buildings were
bumped
uh my building is okay but the building
where i live is okay but uh
my friends buildings
like you know my friends my family uh
buildings are bumped my close friend
called me and she said that her mother's
building was bomb and it's not like you
know it's true
and a lot of uh
in her zone it's about 50 or 60
guys
were killed they tried to meet russian
tank with molotov cocktails and they
died
they just
shouted them so
has the bombing now stopped
uh
i don't think so because we heard a lot
of explosions we live not far from
airport areas so we can hear everything
is going on there so we heard a lot of
explosions at night
and
in the morning today
but as far as i know they don't
bomb city right now but uh my friend's
house uh the day before yesterday uh was
shouted from the um refill
sorry not my friend's house but the
house next to her yes
that's still happening um so what is
your plan are you just going to stay and
not leave your your apartment how long
can you do that for
uh
it's very hard to say about the plan now
there is no green corridor for her son
not only for people that want to live
but also we cannot get food
there is now negotiations as far as you
know going
our mayor trying to
figure out how to create green corridor
or corridor all people try to help and
to
attract
government's attention to us but
now i'm just planning to stay in the
apartment because we are surrounded by
russian army and it's very dangerous now
not only go outside but leave the city
so for now we're just sitting we have
enough food for a couple weeks
so
that's planned for now
and your grandmother i understand is
also there how does she feel about
living uh in a town with russian tanks
and forces out on the streets
she's scared she's angry as all of us
but uh we are standing with ukraine we
have trust in our army we we trust in
our victory so
she's very you know she's very strong
woman she's she inspires me so it's very
nice that we are together now so we can
support each other and
you know
it's it helps to hang on and heading up
in this situation
well svetlana uh please stay safe
svetlana zarina ukrainian talk to us
there from curson a town that has now
been taken over it seems by russian
troops thanks very much for joining us
well in the uk people with families
still in the ukraine are of course
growing increasingly concerned for their
safety with relatives sleeping in
shelters to escape russian shelling one
of those we've spoken to says that the
situation is driving them insane here's
our community's correspondent lisa
hollande
as the war intensifies relatives
watching all this from afar are becoming
increasingly frantic
this is kharkiv where just a few weeks
ago ola buskin took this happy family
photo visiting her mother orlina
cradling granddaughter emilia on her
first birthday
ola lives in essex now she's on the
phone to her mother who's in a bunker
beneath the school where she works as a
math teacher
i'm going absolutely insane honestly
i don't know what is
why wise way to do to let you stay there
and wait until she will run out with
your food and medication or to let her
out of the car of the basically the
shelter
and
try to get you out of the train station
but it's no guarantee that any of this
move going to be safe
holler says this video was taken in
kharkiv a few days ago in the street
where her grandfather lived her uncle
and two cousins work in a hospital in
the city with patients sheltering
underground they say it's overwhelmed
i just want all this to stop says ola's
cousin alexandra civilians are getting
hurt our lives have become hell
ukrainian vitali yalahusian is a student
in sheffield his parents are in the
capital kiev his frightened mother has
been sleeping not in her bedroom but on
the floor close to the front door so she
can flee underground more quickly i
helped her to organize a whole trip
for her to get
food and water i was sitting all night
going through google maps and social
media websites looking for supermarkets
that are reportedly
have some and something left in stock
for now relatives can only wait for news
hoping for the day they'll be reunited
lisa holland sky news
well already in this war russia has been
accused of using illegal cluster bombs
fragments of which are said to have been
found in a children's playground so are
there any rules in urban warfare and how
much consideration do generals give to
the risks to civilians or damage to the
infrastructure of the town that they're
in but i'm joined now by research
analyst and intelligence surveillance
and reconnaissance expert sam cranny
evans um sam good to talk to you
what is actually happening on the ground
as far as you're able to glean
hi good morning um it seems that there
are a few different lines of advance for
the russian forces at the moment
and
certainly there is one that is
attempting to threaten kiev
and although that is the one about which
we seem to be hearing the worst news for
the russian forces and those advances in
the the south around uh
crimea and in donbass seem to be more
stable
and so yes the the situation overall is
i think worsening for the ukrainian
forces unfortunately
what about the russian tactics it seems
to be that they're trying to sort of lay
siege to cities and towns starving them
with supplies
how how does that play out in a war
situation how long does it take
i think that has uh perhaps been a on
the ground sort of reaction to
um
the initial results i think perhaps the
russian forces were assuming a an easier
campaign one that would have
less stiff resistance than they have
encountered
um so their hope was that
the zelen
team
would you know consider negotiations and
discussions to end the violence
that the
pressure that they're now exerting on
the cities is likely a
a response to this increased resistance
and the hope is that they'll increase
the pain to the ukrainian population
and that will be leveraged for political
gains in terms of how long it takes it
really depends on how well the
population was prepared how much time
they've had to gather supplies and
ammunition and how stiff the ukrainian
resistance is in those cities
okay uh samuel cranny evans i'm afraid
we don't have any more time but it's
really good to talk to you thanks a lot
for joining us on sky news this morning
well you're watching sky news breakfast
we are live on both sides of the border
uh both in poland and ukraine this
morning i'm on the polish side
in a town
this is where a lot of the people who
are coming from live by train are
arriving they're being met here
we're going to talk to some of the
people who've arrived here throughout
the course of the morning we're also
going to be joined by our correspondents
on the other side of the border inside
ukraine stay with sky news as russia's
invasion of ukraine enters its eighth
day
[Music]